hey you guys ever used that thunderdome
or do you just put it up for decoration
uh you mean the blood down save it for
the semantics doe me be white episode
two takes place primarily in a
diesel-powered
vehicular field of death and nihilism
morty shoot the mohawk guy was probably
my favorite episode to work on because
the cars themselves could have so much
character with spikes and bones and
other kind of like fun a
post-apocalyptic come on that was a
heavy episode there's like a set of
bleachers around the Thunderdome there
must have been like 80 characters just
in that one shot I like every character
to be different to make my life harder
so if you look in the backgrounds these
scenes you will see a different person
in every seat assume that this is a
world where went down in the 90s and now
this is like the result of it like 90s
punkers and stuff like that and then of
course like just like in Mad Max where
there's a little hint of it we like
really played up the BDSM gear we would
do things where like someone's wearing a
gas mask but then there's like a tube
that goes to their crotch or something I
mean obviously this is an S&M influence
in the characters in the
post-apocalyptic world that's what it's
all about and you're gonna be wearing
masks as spikes and chains and exposed
muscles and things tied around their
body parts and go back to the primal
when it's supposed to five clips sex and
violence and how they intertwine
the family - the dead
how long have you all been eating poop
we have never eaten poop rick and morty
all-new episodes begins Sunday July 30th
11:30 hey youtubers we're getting new
Rick and Morty next Sunday night it's
gonna be awesome episode two so be sure
to subscribe to get everything I'll be
doing videos all season long the episode
two obviously as you can see is going to
be that Mad Max fury road episode called
Rick man Singh the stone they actually
do go after a stone in the episode but
the title is just a reference to
Romancing the stones of Michael Douglas
Kathleen Turner movie from way back in
the 80s but they actually screened the
episode at Comic Con so let me know if
you were in that comic-con crowd there
are about 4,000 people sitting here
there were about another 4,000 people
that they said that they had to turn
away so it was nuts
they had a great comic-con panel theirs
was happening at the same time as Game
of Thrones but it always happens that
way anything that you loved will have
its comic-con panel at the same time as
something else on the other side of the
convention center
[Music]
and if you were to fabricate a fake
memory would you start from scratch
blank page complete or what you
maybe pull from some real things that
might happen make some edits some tweaks
you know I mean like if you're gonna
Photoshop how cool is that they actually
said that Rick's fake backstory in
episode 1 is part true so you can take
that and run with it but they said that
they basically try not to step on the
Canon that they set up in episodes so
that it fans want to carry that forward
they don't trample on it by saying that
it's not real they really enjoy all the
theory crafting that people do but if
you guys do want me to upload the rest
of the comic-con panel let me know and
I'll do that in the next couple days but
the episode itself just picks up where
episode 1 left off it's like the Smith
family trying to get used to life
without Jerry he's moving out you
started to see what the dynamic is gonna
be like while he's not living with them
and then Rick needs to get a stone so
they go to this alternate earth so this
is happening in present day like this
post-apocalyptic future remember that as
a show Rick and Morty doesn't mess with
time travel they only travel to
present-day on other earth so that's why
they explained that something really bad
happened on this earth in the 90s and
now they're all wearing BDSM gear and
acting like Mad Max they have a version
of immortan joe from fury road summer
winds up killing one of them while
they're trying to escape so by the rules
of the apocalypse they invite her to
join their scavengers group so summer is
hardcore in this episode this is from
later in the episode when they're still
trying to steal that glowing stone he
injects Morty with DNA from one of their
big gladiators so that's why Morty's arm
looks like it's super big the arm itself
starts to take over Morty purge in all
style and he's just beats the out
of everybody else in Thunderdome but he
starts to understand why everybody's so
crazy in this world summer winds up
falling in love with their version of
immortan joe the metaphor of the episode
through Morty's giant arm in summer is
letting go so it's like you let go of
Jerry their life is changing so that's
like the big theme of the episode
they do it using all this Mad Max stuff
then once they convey that really nice
metaphor rick goes full rig on their
society and messes the entire planted up
completely changing everything so that
all the more tea and summer want to do
is just go home so that's their way of
sort of resetting things back to base
like how do we get summer away from this
crazy dude they all learned they need to
be strong in this new life and they sort
of settle down a little bit but it does
seem like there's more of a
serialization to the episodes than there
has been in the past but you have the
Galactic government in the early seasons
but now we're like directly picking up
with the events of the previous episodes
so it's not completely serialized you
could still watch them out of order but
I think it'll just make it a little bit
more fun when you start binging this
after the season is over and Yuri watch
the episodes but either way the good
news is that the TV Guide is listing
that Episode two is gonna drop on Sunday
instead of them just re airing episode
one although they might rerun it before
Episode two airs either way completely
new episode it's gonna be awesome
what will happen is is my Rick and Morty
videos because Game of Thrones is on
Sunday nights and so much of my time is
dedicated to that most of my Rick and
Morty stuff will post early Monday
morning until Game of Thrones is over
there are only five more episodes of
Game of Thrones there's ten episodes of
Rick and Morty this season so once Game
of Thrones is over then Rick and Morty
will just dominate my Sundays believe
all your requests for bonus videos in
the comments below while you wait for
everything you can click here to rewatch
that season 3 trailer and you can click
here for that next game of Thrones
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]